marinating the lamb first Cheers we'll
use a mixture of red and green take off
the tops and just slice in garlic
don't worry about chopping these ultra
fine just get it in there cooking up to
three hours everything's got a blends
and almost sort of cures itself together
smoked paprika it goes brilliantly well
with the chilies 2 teaspoons in a touch
of dried oregano some little cumin seeds
the blend and the fragrance so they give
out is extraordinary they release a
little oil as well helps to tenderize
the lamb touch of salt pepper cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb olive
oil just a tablespoon and the olive all
helps to sort of stick all those
wonderful spices to the lamb jump in
just start really rubbing at this stage
you can leave the lamb to marinate for
anything from half an hour to overnight
allowing the spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results when you
tuck in delicious vegetables carrots and
onions and that's it sliced secret
slicing vegetables for braising is not
getting too thin you slice the onions
too thin they burn you've got that
horrible char taste on that slow braised
braising it's just a chef's term that
means cooking in liquid on a low heat
making the meat incredibly moist and
beautifully tender so the secret of
braising is having a really nice thick
durable pan get that nice and hot just a
touch of olive oil
lamin hold the bone you can control them
into the pan
on that white fats to start rendering so
we'll have more fat therefore making it
a lot more flavor some as it braises
chilies cinnamon in mix that up and
don't be scared you're not burning this
you're sort of searing the lamb shanks
and this is the important part right at
the very beginning we're gonna be color
on the lamb which washes off as it
braises in the oven so be generous with
that color vegetables in WoW and then
cut the Bailey's so now you lift the
lamb up and get the lamb sat on top of
the vegetables now the blade the pan
with red wine the glazing means that
you're you cleaning the bottom of the
pan and you're getting that amazing
flavor washed off and lift it up into
that sauce it can really transform that
dish always it lays then bring to the
boil and cook for about ten minutes to
reduce the wines reduce down by half
now that the stock bring that stock back
up to the ball and then into the oven
now don't cover it when you cover it all
the conversation comes off the lid your
lamb becomes gray all this effort and
that exciting spice gets washed away no
lid and in the oven for three hours a
slow cook on a low heat of a hundred and
sixty degrees gives us Pisces time to
work and transform the meat so it's
mouth-wateringly tender now
look at those out on to a plate you can
just see that meat sliding down juicy
and incredibly tender grab it by the
shank roll them around that rich
delicious sauce
these sauce
nice beautiful just get some mint don't
chop it just pick that fresh mint and
let it snow and there you go a very
spicy delicious melting in the mouth
lamb shank amazing
[Music]
now the secret whisking is a big
beautiful blue and whisk the bigger the
blue that we meet sliding down juicy and
creamy tender